a reminder if you need one uh that your
quiz is on Monday the first 30 minutes
of class it'll cover everything in
capital structure which is the first
part of the second packet so it's about
tw so we'll be done with capital
structure about 30 minutes into today,
but it covers the financing mix, the
cost of capital approach, what happens
when you buy back
stock or ending through duration of
debt, matching up, you know, getting the
right type debt for your company. And
I'll talk a little bit about that
duration of debt issue because it comes
up in every one of the third quizzes
you've seen so far in terms of pure
mechanics and why if you understood the
unlevered beta process and how we dealt
with it, you can also deal with the
duration aspect. So let's say where we
left off on um on Monday. We were
talking about the right debt for Disney
and we actually went through the macro
data, interest rates, inflation, GDP,
trying to get a sense of what drives
Disney's numbers, right? Not just their
operating earnings, but their value as a
company. It's a purely datadriven
approach. So rather than making
subjective judgments about my company
cyclical, my company has pricing power,
you let the data tell you whether your
company has pricing power. So let's
review. The first when you run the
regression against interest rates,
you're getting a measure of the duration
of your company's assets. Why? Because
for every 1% change in interest rates,
your value drops by 5%. That's
essentially the equivalent of having a
duration of 5 years. When you run the
regression against real GDP, you're
getting a measure of is my company truly
cyclical. If it is truly cyclical, the
coefficient you should get when you look
at real GDP should be a big positive
number. So when your GDP is doing well,
your earnings and value should go up. If
that coefficient is zero, your company
is not cyclical. If it's negative, your
company could actually be
counteryclical. When you run the
regression against inflation, you're
getting a measure of pricing power
because if you have pricing power,
inflation should show through. It should
show up in your earnings, should show up
in your value. If it doesn't show up,
then you don't have pricing power no
matter how much you think you might do.
And then when we ran the regression
against a weighted dollar, we got an
answer question. How does a stronger
dollar affect my company? Cuz you take a
US company, a stronger dollar can help
them. It can do nothing for them or hurt
them. And again, it's a purely empirical
question. So it's entirely datadriven.
And it'll work if you have a company
with a long history. But what else has
to be true about your company for that
long history to answer those questions?
So let's say you have 50 years of
history on an AT&T in fact with AT&T you
have 120 years of
history why is much of that history
useless when you look at AT&T
today it's a very different company
right for much of that 120 years it was
a monopoly it was the monopoly any
anybody with for so sometimes you have a
lot of history and it's not telling you
much even in the case of Disney I have
quite using it cuz Disney as a company
has changed so much over that 30-year
period that I looked at the date. It
started as primarily an animated movie
theme park company. It acquired Cap
Cities ABC in 96. It became this
broadcasting company. Then it bought
more movie franchises, Star Wars,
Avengers and then it entered the
streaming business.
So, one of the reasons you when you look
at historical data, you got to be a
little careful is that data can give you
numbers and the numbers that I'm getting
for Disney reflect the 30-year history,
but I'm not sure they're good numbers
going forward. In fact, I have a second
issue. If you remember, I showed you the
standard errors, the tstistics for each
of these coefficients, and they were
very for many of these regressions, the
coefficients are either not
statistically significant or barely
significant. There's a lot of noise in
the regression, which is a nice way of
saying in statistics. Hey, there are
lots of things I can't explain with this
regression. I think we ran into this
problem one time before in this class,
right? Where else in this class have we
used a regression to come up with the
metric and then said that's noisy. I
really don't trust that number. It was
here when we did betas, right? And there
what was the solution we adopted?
We looked at the average beta across a
lot of companies. How did that save you?
It's a standard error issue. When you
look at the average, you're removing the
noise. You see where I'm going to go
next, right? So, when I computed the
duration for Disney, I ran one
regression of Disney's numbers against
the past and I came up with this minus
2.33. But the statistical significance
of that number was non-existent. The t
statistic was less than one.
What if I could run this
regression for every company in the
entertainment
business? That's going to be an insane
amount of work. But let's say I was
willing to do it, right? And I could
give you an average for that coefficient
across all companies in the sector.
You'd now have a bottomup estimate of
duration for the company. And because
Disney is in multiple businesses, here's
what I did. If this table looks remotely
like another table we did, it's
intentional. Remember how we got bottom
up bases? We broke Disney down into five
businesses. And there we estimated the
bait of each business. In this table,
instead of doing that, I'm computing the
average coefficient I got when I ran
regressions against interest rates, real
GDP, inflation of other companies in
this business. So, think of these as
bottomup estimates of the duration of
Disney. the pricing power of Disney.
There's there's stuff I lose when I do
these bottom up estimates that are
specific to Disney, but there's a great
deal that I gain. So, if you trust this
these bottom up coefficients, it looks
like the weighted average, and again,
the weights are exactly the same way as
they were with with unle bet. It's
weighted by value of the business is
minus4.34. The minus 2.33 I got from
running just the Disney regression is
now in the trash can. and I'm going to
replace with the minus
4.34. The duration for Disney's that
roughly speaking should be about 4.3
years if I trust the bottom up estimate.
So again, the parallels between beta and
what we're doing here should come into
play. We're just taking the average
because it gives you more precise
number. So all you see there are the
averages across all of the macro
variables. They will replace the
individual regression.
I told you it's an insane amount of
work. It's so much work. I don't update
these numbers every year. It took me an
entire two weeks to actually run these
regressions once. So I do them once
every 10 years. I'm hoping to do them
once every 100 years. That's why I'm one
and done because I don't think I have to
do the second iteration. I won't be
around. But you I will send you this
latest version which is from like six
years ago. So when you I don't want you
to run. So when you run the macro
regression for your company and you get
strange looking numbers, I don't want
you to spend two days trying to figure
out why the numbers look strange. It's
statistics. There's a lot of noise. Just
replace them with the bottomup numbers.
Move on to the next part of the
project. So here's the bottom line. When
you look at Disney, I can tell you what
Disney's debt should look like. It
should be pretty long-term with a
duration of roughly 4.3 years. So 4.3
comes from the weighted average bottom
up. Hey, a significant portion of the
debt should be floating rate debt. I
won't even specify what percentage
because there's no easy way to do it.
Why? Because it looks like Disney has
pricing
power. And
intuitively, I think it does. I do think
that given how that Disney's earnings
and value are sensitive to the US
dollar, a portion of the debt should be
in non dollar non-doll currencies. And
if you look at the geographic breakdown,
maybe that'll give us a lead at 2013 it
was 82% US, 18% of the rest of the
world. Today it's about 70% US, 30% of
the rest of the world. I would like the
debt to match. So I have a sense of what
Disney's debt should look like. And then
I open up Disney's balance sheet. And
what am I going to see there? I'm going
to see what Disney's actual debt looks
like. Disney in 2013 had $14.3 billion
in interestbearing debt with a weight
with a face value weighted maturity of
about 7.92 years. You remember the 7.92
years was what we used to get the market
value of the debt. Basically that's I
need to have a duration of roughly 4.3
years. The maturity is 7.9 years. I
can't compare
maturity to
duration. Why is that France? Why can't
I compare maturity to duration?
because you get coupons over the life of
bond, right? So when you look at
maturity, it's going to overstate the
because I'm going to get a coupon in
year 1, two. So when I have a maturity
for a bond of 10 years, its duration
will be lower because I so the 7.92
years has duration of roughly six maybe
six and a half years. So, it looks like
my Disney debt is a little too
long-term, but not a huge difference.
It's not like 17 versus 4. It's about 6
versus 4 of the debt. About 5 12% of the
debt is in non dollar currencies
primarily in Hong Kong dollars because
they funded the Hong Kong theme park
with Hong Kong dollar debt. That looks
too low to me. Why? Because I know that
18% of their operations are outside the
US. The 5.49% 49% looks too low. So, I'm
adding up ammunition on what I think
Disney should do differently. Slightly
more short-term
debt, more foreign currency debt, and
about 5.6% of their debt is in floating
rate debt. And that too looks like it's
too low given the pricing power Disney
has. So I have my recommendations for
their de what the their debt should look
like, what their actual debt looks like,
and I can see a mismatch. It's not an
immense mismatch. This is not exactly
something I have to go fix right away.
For some companies, the mismatch can be
so horrific, you can say, you know what,
I've got to do something right now
because this company has a mismatch
problem. Take BU. 80% of their debt is
in foreign currency. All their revenues
are in
Chinese. So the first thing I'm going to
check with the companies, have you done
something about it? And they might have,
right? What could they have done to fix
a mismatch?
Wait, they could have taken off swaps.
They could have done swaps. So show me
evidence that you're doing something
that you know there's a problem because
if you if you say what problem then I
have a problem with that, right? So if
you know there's a problem, you've done
something. So, so if you see a mismatch,
that's the next step is before you jump
and decide the company has a problem,
check to see if they're aware of the
problem and they're doing something
about the
problem. In this case, there's a
mismatch. It's not huge, but if I wanted
to fix it, here are my
choices. I can swap some of my debt to
make my overall debt look better. What
does that mean? Remember, I want my debt
to be more less long-term, more foreign
currency, and more floating rate debt,
right? So, here's what I'll do. I'll
take some of my fixed rate dollar debt,
preferably long-term, and swap it for
floating rate euro debt, which is more
short-term. Essentially, I'm fixing my
debt by replacing some of my debt with
debt that better suits me, right? I can
use derivatives
options, futures to kind of manage that
risk, try to make my I mean the the the
levers you have today to
fix a essentially a mismatcher are far
more powerful than they would have been
50 years. 50 years ago, you'd have it to
repay debt and replace them with new
debt. Today, you don't have to do it.
So, I can uh do swap I can use swaps. I
can use derivatives. And there's a third
third factor here to consider. Disney is
still growing. It's still investing. Its
next theme park at that time is already
talking about is going to be in
Shanghai, a really expensive theme park
and they have to finance it, right? So
when I when they ask me how should you
finance the Shanghai debt first I'm
going to suggest know more short-term
than they typically use because I want
the overall debt to become more
short-term preferably in a foreign
currency because I want more foreign and
if you can make it floating rate even
better so you can take the next debt
issue you make and effectively use it as
a way of kind of fixing that mismatch
between where you are today and where
you'd like to be In much of the world,
mismatches are embedded. They're baked
into companies balance sheets because of
their history. 20 years ago, if you are
not a US company, when you wanted to
borrow money, guess where that debt came
from? You're an Indian company, an
Indonesian
company. You borrowed from a bank,
usually a local bank. And when you
borrow from the bank, what was the
structure of the debt? Whatever the bank
said you could borrow at. So everybody
borrowed a 10-year fixed rate debt
because that's what banks would lend
at. So it's not that these companies
were not savvy, they just didn't have
the choices and a lot of that debt is
still on their balance
sheet. So before we get fancy about
financing mix and changing the debt of a
company, this is a much simpler fix to
make now is an Indian company today has
choices it did not have 20 years ago. So
when it has debt that's 20-year fixed
rate debt, but it's basic businesses you
need floating rate foreign currency debt
today. You can make that choice and fix
it fairly quickly. So I would start with
that process. So what I'd like you to
try to do with your company is before
you look at the balance sheet, think
about intuitively what kind of debt
would I expect this company to be,
long-term or short-term? What currency,
fixed or floating rate? Make that choice
first. Then look at the debt on the
balance sheet and does this debt make
sense for my company? I briefly
mentioned that in the last session that
the debt you see in businesses often
reflects what's right for that
business. In retail, a big chunk of the
debt you will have for your company
comes from leases,
right? How do leases match up? You
basically your assets are stores.
What does a lease do? It matches the
debt up to the store in terms of
location, in terms of life, in terms of
and in fact, if the store does really
badly in many cases on that individual
lease, you have escape hatches you can
use. Leases are the right debt for most
retailers because they reflect that the
way you grow, the way you invest. So,
when you look at your company, that's
what you're looking at. Is is the kind
of debt that I have the kind of debt I
would expect to see in this company? And
then if you can if you see a mismatch,
you can't fix it obviously in a project,
but you can say this is these are some
of the things they can do. They're a
growing company. They're taking
projects. On the next few projects, I
would suggest they take this type of
debt to get back to a
match. Now, for my other companies, I'm
going to be briefer in terms of the debt
design because clearly by now you can
see the process, right? You can work
through. In the case of Bookscape,
they're a retailer in New
York. I think the right the kind of debt
they have right now is lease debt. I
think that matches up to what they
should be having given their the their
location, their currency, their the type
of assets. Val, it's mostly mines.
That's what you're financing with your
debt. The mines tend to have very long
lives and they're all over the world,
right? You have Canadian mines, you have
Brazilian mines, you might have mines
in, I don't know, parts of Asia. So when
you look at the kind of debt, it should
be long-term debt. And here it should be
dollar denominated for the most part, no
matter where they are in the world for a
simple reason. Commodity companies live,
at least for the moment, still in a
dollar denominated world. The markets
are dollardriven.
So with commodity companies, it does
make sense that no matter where you are
in the world, you try to use US dollar
debt. Their actual debt is primarily US
dollar debt with an average maturity of
15 years. It was a company with the
longest maturity, at least in a very
rough sense. That does make sense for
Bali. Patarda Motors, it's a
manufacturing company with one very big
external arm in in the form of Jaguar
Land Rover. I would expect that that to
be very different for the mass market
Indian automobile business as opposed to
the luxury auto business. They have very
little pricing power within India. So
when they issue debt to fund that that
those business that business I would
expect to be fixed rate debt preferably
long-term in rupees. But for Jaguar Land
Rover they have more choices. It can it
clearly should be foreign currency.
Perhaps there's more pricing power there
which gives you floating rate debt. So
choices become richer. The existing debt
for Tatamotus is a mix of rupee and euro
debt with an average maturity of about 5
years. So I mean it doesn't look off. It
looks pretty close to what you'd expect
it to be. They don't have any floating
rate debt. I would expect them to have a
little bit of that. So maybe that's the
one change you'd expect. BU is the one
company in my mix at least that had
mismatched debt that was dramatically
mismatched. No, I would expect the debt
to be in Chinese yuan and because it's a
growing company is the kind of company
that should be using convertible debt
because the variance the risk actually
works in their favor. They have no
convertible debt. It's all straight
debt. So maybe they know that they know
there's a problem. But there was nothing
in the financials that I saw that told
me that they were using any kind of
swaps. But they don't have to. It's not
something that you have to disclose
necessarily because it's part of your,
you know, dayto-day, month-to-month
operations. But that's a question I
would ask them. What are you doing about
dealing with this mismatch between the
fact that all of your operations are in
yuan, but your debt is a foreign
currency?
So before I start on dividend policy, I
want to talk a little bit about that
final problem you have on every one of
your third quizzes going back probably
20 years. It's a problem that deals with
this debt mismatch question and it's
usually about the duration of the debt,
right? So all of these problems will
start with an existing
firm. The existing firm is in
businesses. has a certain amount of
debt. My suggestion is the same one that
I made when I talked about beta. Start
with the equivalent of a balance sheet,
right? You have assets, you have
liabilities. Start off by looking at
what businesses is this company in and
asking what is the duration of those
businesses. So, usually the prom will
specify this company. So, let's make up
a prompt. Yeah. And it'll give you kind
of a window into how I write these last
prompts. So, let's take a company. Leon,
help me out. Put the company in any two
businesses you want. Any two that you
want. What's EDP?
ADP. Oh, two companies. No, two
businesses.
Yeah. Like steel and chemicals or Yeah.
Steel. Steel and farm. So, you're in two
businesses. And I give you the duration
of each of these businesses. How do I
get the duration? Maybe I did the bottom
up durations for companies. the
business. So let's say the steel
business has a duration of 10 years and
the farmer business has a duration of 25
years, right? And I'll tell you how much
value the company gets from each
business. That'll be given in the
problem. So let's say it gets 800
million from pharma and 200 million from
steel. So 800 times. So the duration is
a weighted average just like betas are.
So you have a weighted average duration
of the businesses this company is in. So
the problem gives you that. Then I'll
also tell you how the company is funded
right now. I'll say right now you know
because you have what 20 in this case
the collective value of the assets and
the liabilities I have to say 80% of
your value is in equity 20% in debt and
I'll give you the duration of the
existing debt. So the problem always
starts by specifying what the company
looks like right now. So draw the
duration you know balance sheet you have
duration of the assets duration of the
debt. The second part of the problem
always follows a script. something
happens at the firm that changes the
asset side like what you do an
acquisition. Why does it change the
acquis asset side? You're bringing a new
asset with perhaps a different duration.
So this company decides to enter the AI
business. Why? Because everybody else is
entering into it. You have no idea what
the business is, but you spent some
money getting into it. And I give you
the duration of that new
business. First step in all of these
problems is work with the asset side.
Remember how with unlevas we always work
with the assets side take the unlev beta
of the new business mix this company is
going to
have and usually the problem specify how
I
fund that change. So in the case of an
acquisition I'll say I'm borrowing the
money to fund the acquisition and here's
where the question that the problem will
ask will come into play. The question
the problem will be what will the
duration of the new debt have to be to
get the duration of my debt to be equal
to the duration of my assets after the
acquisition. So you do the acquisition,
you compute the new duration of the
assets. You have the existing debt with
the existing duration. You're taking on
new duration and I'm asking you what the
duration of that debt should be. That's
the x in your equation. You solve for
it. Every single problem will follow
that script.
So if you see twists, it'll always be
around those. What can the twist be?
Instead of acquiring something, I could
devest a portion of an existing
business, right? Why will that change
duration? Because the weights will
change. So if I'm d, you know, devesting
myself of, you know, half of one of my
businesses, the duration of my asset
side will change. Then I'll have to tell
you what the cashes used to do. Maybe
I'll buy back stock or retire some of my
debt. And the question might be you know
what how much of the debt will I have to
retire to get the duration to match up.
So focus on what's happening before the
change and then look at the effect of
the change on the duration of the ass
and the duration of the debt. Exactly
the same framework we used when we
thought about betas but now we're using
it to ask what's the right duration of
my new
debt. So now let's talk about the third
and the final piece of corporate
finance. Right.
Before we start the discussion of
dividend policy, I'm going to make a
statement about cash and dividends that
I think will animate how we think about
dividends. You're a shareholder in a
company, let's say Apple. How much cash
does Apple
have? Lot, right? 200
billion. But let me reframe that. Apple
has no cash. It's holding your
cash. You being the shareholders cash.
companies have no cash. What you see as
a cash balance is shareholders cash. It
kind of changes the entire framework for
the discussion, right? Because when you
show up at an annual meeting, what do
you have to do right now? You got to beg
the managers to pay you a bigger
dividend. Beg the managers to buy back
more stock. Why? Cuz managers at
companies seem to think the cash belongs
to
them. And your interlopers who show up
asking for dividends and they give you a
little dividend. is supposed to go away.
The truth is, if this were a fair
universe, you know what managers in
every company would have to do every
year? They'd have to get up and beg you
to leave your cash with
them every
year. Unfortunately, that you know, we
don't live in that world of corporate
governance. So, we're going to look at
cash return from the framework of, hey,
what should shareholders expect to see
from a company? And when a company
chooses not to do that, what happens at
the company? And what can you as a
shareholder do in reaction? So there are
two basic questions I'm going to try to
answer in the next two, three, maybe
even four sessions. First is when you
look at a company, how much cash can a
company choose to how much cash can a
company return to its shareholders? Your
first reaction might be well it can
return its
earnings as dividends. Well, that's not
necessarily true, right? Wade, why not?
Why can't I return earnings as
dividends? Earnings are calculated on a
cruel basis, so it may not reflect the
actual earnings are not cash flows,
right? You can have a company with
billions of dollars in earnings and not
even if earnings are cash flows, why
can't I return the cash? You need it to
grow the business. Exactly. Right. So,
earnings are not what you can afford to
pay out. It's the cash left over after
you've covered the needs to meet future
growth required. So, we're going to have
to estimate what that cash will be. It's
surprisingly simple to
do. I'm going to, you know, come up with
a with a term called free cash flowed
equity, which is essentially cash left
over after you've met every need. And
we'll talk about what that cash flow
will look like over time. The second
question I have to ask and that's it's
become an increasingly critical question
is in what
form? When I started teaching corporate
finance almost no I mean this is early
1980s 198384 was my first corporate
finance class very few firms bought back
stock. If you were returning cash to
your shareholders was usually in the
form of dividends and in much of the
world this still remains true right but
in the US increasingly of two ways of
returning cash. You can either pay it
out as a dividend or you can buy back
shares. And I think that choice has been
complicated by people bringing in
distractions about both items. So I want
to talk about hey which one is the
better choice? What is the tradeoff you
have to think of as shareholders as to
why you might pick one over the other?
So let's start this discussion by
looking at how dividends would be set in
a rational
universe. What's the definition of
equity? And we talked about equity
versus debt. Debt has a contractual
claim. You remember what equities claim?
What was the equity claim?
Residual, right? Which basically means
you get whatever's left over. So if the
universe were a just universe, you ran
businesses with that in mind. Your
dividend should be the last step in the
process. You're looking at what's left
over. It should come after you've done
all of the other stuff in the company.
Start with the earnings. You cover your
your operating needs, your capital
expenditures, your working capital, your
debt payments. Remember, all of those.
And what's left at the end should be
what you pay out as
dividends. And if that were the case,
your dividend should swing wildly from
year to year, right? Because it should
be low in bad years, high in good years,
should be zero when you're having a
negative cash flow year. Already you can
see that that is not the way the
universe works.
The way companies pay dividends, it
doesn't look like it's a residual claim.
How do we
know? For most companies, when you look
at the dividends this year, what do they
look like? Dividends last year and the
year before and the year before. This is
not how a residual claim works. So, if
you look at dividends, I think you see
the essence of it's the most
dysfunctional part of corporate finance.
Dysfunctional. What sense? Well, a lot
of companies when you look at what they
pay in dividends, it doesn't reflect any
kind of residual cash flow. It's fixed.
It's rigid. You say why do they do what
they do? The two forces that seem to
drive how much companies return as
dividends is
inertia. Inertia reflects what what have
we always we companies actually boast
about the fact that they've paid
dividends for the last 142 years.
There's a bank out there that's paid
dividends for congratulations. You've
broken every rule in what dividends is
supposed to be. But it becomes we pay
dividends for 142
years. Chat GPT must be running your
company, right? Because you say how much
should we pay in dividends? You look at
dividends last year, you pay it out this
year. The other is me too isn't. Why do
you pay what you do in dividends?
Because everybody else in our peer group
also pays dividends. You're a bank. It
is very difficult to be a bank that
doesn't pay a dividend because every
bank seems to pay a dividend.
So in the real world, dividends don't
always reflect that residual claim.
They're often said for reasons that have
nothing to do with what a company can
pay. So I'm going to start by listing
out some facts about dividend policy
based on the
data. And this comes from our discussion
so far. If you ask me to use one word to
describe dividends in the US, and I'll
talk about the rest of the world as
well, the word I would use is
sticky. Okay, let me back that up. In
this graph, I have the number of or the
percentage of US companies each year
that increase dividends. That's a green
column. The percentage of US companies
each year that cut
dividends, that's a red column. If I
pause right there, you can already see
the the the mismatch, right? Far more
companies increase than decrease
dividends. About 3 to 14. Even in really
bad years, 2009,
2020, more companies increase and
decrease dividends. But in every single
year, the percentage of companies that
pay exactly what they did last year
outnumbers companies that change
dividends. It's the sticky part. Most
companies pay out what they did last
year. So if you take your company and it
pays dividends, look at its history on a
per share basis because it's sticky on a
per share
basis. 25 cents per share, 50 cents per
share, because that's what we've always
paid. This is true in much of the rest
of the world, but it depends on what
part of dividend policy is sticking. In
Latin America, rather than pay sticky
dollar or absolute dividends, it's
sticky payout ratios. A certain
percentage of earnings gets returned
every
year. The reason for that is we in much
of Latin America, you have these voting
and non- voting shares. The non- voting
shares are triggered by not paying out a
certain percentage. So you they get
voting claims if you don't pay out 30%
or 40% of earnings. So it's almost
locked in. So in much of the world
dividends are sticky which cuts against
a residual claim right in a residual
world dividend shouldn't be sticky but
they are second now. So even in 2020
terrible year 287 companies so
increased dividends 11 cut dividends and
the 11 that cut dividends made history.
That's an unusually large number in the
S&P 500 to cut dividends in a particular
year. you know, of the S&P 500
companies, 27 increased dividends and 42
suspended dividends. You know, I think
this was in the second quarter of 2020.
So, basically, you see that even in bad
quarters, companies continue to pay what
they did in dividends. Extraordinarily
sticking. Second way to describe
dividends, they tend to follow earnings.
Key word is follow. They don't lead
earnings. They're not contemporaneous.
So, here's dividends and earnings over
time. It's tough to read the columns,
but basically you can see the payout
ratios kind of moved all over the place,
but over time, the red column almost
never decreases on a year-to-year basis.
But earnings have good years and bad
years. So, if you have a company that
has a good year with earnings, I
wouldn't expect dividends to go up this
year. There's two good years, maybe
it'll go up next year. If there three
good years, then you might see dividend
increase. Managers seem to wait increase
dividend. In fact, take the two parts
that we've had so far. Sticky where more
increases than decreases and the fact
they fall earnings. You can see why the
two kind of go together, right? Managers
tend to be cautious about raising
dividends unless they feel they can
sustain them. So, when they cut
dividends, it's often uncommon something
bad has happened at the company.
But the third graph is also something
worth remembering. Who gets all these
dividends? It's shareholders, right? Who
are the shareholders in a company? They
can be institutions, but those
institutions hold shares. Remember, when
a mutual fund gets dividends, it comes
to you. So, you will get a tax statement
at the end of the year from the mutual
fund telling you how much you received
in dividends on your mutual fund. So, it
flows through. It could also be
institutions like pension funds that are
investing
So it could be institutions, it could be
individuals, some of them can be tax
exempt, some are taxable. But taxes play
a key role in thinking about
dividends because as individual
investors look back through history, the
tax rate on dividends for much of the US
income tax history was much higher than
the tax rate on capital
gains. You does anybody know when income
taxes were instituted in the US?
It was actually a little bit after the
Supreme Court actually had to rule on
whether the you could have a federal
income tax and it was 1914 or something
that you actually see it kick in, right?
So 1914 you get tax laws and you know
basically you know early on all tax all
income was taxed at one rate. So it was
like 5% was supposed to hit like 2% of
people and they paid 5% of their income
and over time those both those numbers
increased. So higher percentages paid
taxes and the tax rate changed.
Somewhere around
1920 you created there was a second tax
rate created for capital
gains. Capital gains would be you know
what you made on your investments and
you held them longterm. I think early on
that was set at a one-year threshold.
And for much of the 1900s, you had two
different tax rates. One for ordinary
income, 30, 40, 50, or even 70%, and one
for capital gates at a much lower rate.
In fact, when Ronald Reagan was elected
president in 1981, the highest federal
income tax rate on ordinary income was
70%. The capital gains rate was 28%.
So, let's play it through. If you
receive dividends, it's treated as
ordinary income. And that's what it was
for much of the
1900s, you were taxed at 70% on that
income. If you got price appreciation on
that same company and you sold the
stock, you got a 28% tax rate. This
seems like a no-brainer, right? I mean,
who wants to get dividends and get taxed
at
70%. There are people who still chose to
because not everybody got taxed at 70%.
that was the highest tax rate. Maybe
there were people who were not paying
taxes or income who said I'd like. So
already you can see taxes are going to
play a key role in whether your
shareholders want dividends or not. If
your shareholders are all very rich
people, they're probably going to say I
don't want the dividends. You I'm
getting taxed at 70%.
That divergence between what income,
ordinary income was taxed at and
dividends was classified as ordinary
income and what capital gains was
persisted till the
2003 or four tax reform act and for the
first time in US tax history the two you
know dividends and capital gains ended
up with the same tax rate. So starting
in
2004, US companies have been if you
receive cash from US companies either in
dividends or in long-term capital gains,
your tax rate has been roughly the same.
It was 15% in 2004. It went up to 20%.
After Obamacare, Medicare taxes actually
attached to this income as well. So
right now, the tax rate on both
dividends and capital gains in the US is
about 23.6%.
6%. For long-term cap, if you have
short-term capital gains, it's treated
as ordinary income. So, that portion of
income actually gets taxed at a higher
rate than everything else. But dividends
and long-term capital gains are taxed by
23.6%. Last week, I
saw a rumor or a news story or maybe
Trump saying that he would plan to bring
the capital gains tax rate down to zero,
which will open up that difference
again, right, between No. But for the
moment they tax at the same
rate. But US tax reform acts have this
very strange cliff built into them
because of how the Senate passes these
tax bills. The Senate, as those of you
who follow US politics know, has a
filibuster. Now what a filibuster
started with. Senator getting up and
they can talk and talk and talk. But
over time, it's evolved that you need 60
votes to get anything of consequence
passed in the Senate, which means
nothing will get passed, right? Because
it's very difficult to get to 60 votes.
Obamacare passed because it was a very
brief period where you got to I think
the there was the Democrats at 60 votes
for two years before the the thing blew
up. But you almost never get to 60
votes. But there's one
exception every
year which Congress uses to pass tax
reform
acts. It's this loophole. I won't even
call it loophole. This one opening
called a budget reconciliation where you
can get 51 votes and get things of
consequence passed. Everything of
consequence in the last 15 years that's
changed has come through that budget
reconciliation. But it comes with a
catch which is you're allowed to only
pass things which are budgetneutral in
the long term. Nothing Congress does is
budget neutral. So they have to do all
kinds of gaming. And one of the gaming
that they do to get tax reform passed is
they make it a
10-year window. After which what happens
the tax law reverts to what it was
before. But it's a trick which
essentially say it's only 10 years. So
this is not permanent. So the tax loss
we will not have is not not that great
and that effectively allows every tax
reform act to be passed and it creates a
consequence right you have a tax reform
everything changes but only for 10 years
and at the end of the 10th year what
happens you fall off the cliff you go
back to the old tax
law so one of the things that you see
often happening is as these tax laws are
going to shift you start to see people,
companies, investors
reacting. So this is, you know, just
ahead of the Bush the Bush tax reform in
2003, you know. So as you see tax rates
on dividends come down, you see by the
dividends increase because you have a
lower tax rate. But then you get to
2013, you approach a cliff and
everything is going to revert back to
the way it was before 2004. investors
now have to reassess. We're approaching
another cliff. The
2017 tax reform act, which effectively
lowered the federal tax rate to 21%
changed the tax code to on interest
payments, is set to I think to to to go
off the cliff at the end of 2025.
So if you talk about budget
reconciliation this year, part of it is
going to be about extending that act
another 10 years. There's almost certain
that it's not going to be permanent
because you don't have 60 votes, you
have 51 votes to get there. So that's
part of what you're going to see play
out. So in the US, every 10 years you go
into this game of everything could
change in three months. What do we need
to do?
I'll wager that if you had a different
outcome from the November elections,
we'd be approaching a cliff that almost
certainly would have seen a big change
in tax rates at the end of this year,
right? And investors and companies have
to adjust. And you see dividend policies
reflecting that. last quarter of 2012 as
that previous tax reform act was
approaching its
cliff where dividends could you could
see the tax and dividends bounce back up
companies paid out huge amounts in
special dividends in that last quarter
saying this could be the last quarter
where dividends get taxed at a lower
rate now Las Vegas Sands paid out I
think a $3 billion special dividend 52%
of which went to Sheldon ND because he
was a 52% shareholder. So it wasn't
something under underhanded in terms of
what he got. But basically the special
dividend was paid out because people
were afraid that the tax rate on
dividends would go back up to an
ordinary income tax rate 40% 42%
44%. So one of the things to watch this
year especially if there's going to be a
change in the capital gains tax rate is
what happens in terms of people because
if you I mean let's play it out. Let's
assume that part of this package is the
capital gains tax rate goes to
0%. What's going to happen? You're going
to probably see a lot less paid in
dividends, fewer trades at the end of
the year on stocks that have gone up a
lot because you don't want to catch
again. And in the first month of next
year, you're going to see a boom in
trading on those stocks. So you all you
can almost if you're a trader, there's a
whole host of things you can try to do
to take advantage of that. So do tax
laws matter? Absolutely. And especially
so with dividend
policy. Now here again I want to bring
in the rest of the world. In the US
through much of the last century
dividends were taxed at a much higher
tax rate than capital gains. That
difference has gone away. But in every
country the laws are different. In
Switzerland the laws are actually
different. In different parts of
Switzerland each canton has its own laws
on dividends and capital gates. One of
the things I would encourage you to do
if you have a non US company, an Indian
company, a British company, an
Australian company is look at what the
tax laws to individual investors. This
is not about companies. What are the tax
laws on individual investors when they
receive dividends as opposed to selling
shares and collecting capital
gains? I'm familiar with the UK and the
Australian laws at least. In the UK and
Australia, if you're a shareholder in a
company and you receive dividends, you
know what you're allowed to do? Does
anybody
know, you're actually allowed to claim a
tax credit for taxes the company has
paid already on income from which the
dividends are
paid. Let's play it out. Let's suppose
you have $100 million in income. You
have a 25% tax rate, right? Remember,
dividends get paid out of after tax
income. So, you take the 25% tax rate.
You have $75 million after taxes, your
taxes after it. And let's say you pay
the entire 75 million out as dividends,
and you receive a
dividend. Let's say your tax rate is
30%. Normally, when you receive a
dividend, you have to pay 30% of that in
taxes. But in the UK and Australia,
you're allowed to claim the 25% that's
already been paid in taxes as a credit,
which means effectively on dividends,
you get this really low tax rate or a
zero tax rate if your tax rate is less
than the corporate tax
rate. UK and Australia also have some of
the biggest dividend paying companies in
the
world. Why? because you've got a tax law
that essentially makes dividends tax
exempt, but capital gains are still
taxed. There are other parts of the
world where capital gains are not taxed
for lots of different reason. I want to
encourage people to invest in equity
markets and dividends are taxed. So,
take a look at the tax code within your
country and I'll send you a couple of
links if you, you know, if you want one
place where you can go look it up
because it will affect how much
companies pay in
dividends. So, dividends are sticky.
Dividends follow earnings. Dividends are
affected by the tax
code. And there's a fourth and final
piece of this puzzle. And this is, I
think, the biggest shift in dividend
policy that I can point to that's
happened mostly over the last four
decades. As I said early when I started
teaching the class, most of the cash
returned by US companies took the form
of dividends. Back in 1981, 98% of the
cash returned by US companies took the
form of dividends. Buybacks were rare
and they were designed for a very
different
reason. Starting in the mid 80s that
started to shift. So this graph actually
starts in 1988 but even in 88 early in
the process twice as much money with so
the green is the dividends and red is
the stock buybacks twice as much money
was returned in the form of dividends
and buybacks and I've tracked that over
time clearly there are some ups and
downs but you can see during the 1990s
buybacks start to explode and in 1998
for the first time sorry 19 yeah 1998
for the first time in US corpor
corporate history more cash was returned
in the form of buybacks than dividends.
You think that's dot but it it's really
not gone away. In fact, if you look
across time now that red column
consistently I think even except for
2009 where it dropped off and there's
and that should become part of why
buybacks have taken off every single
year buyback and last
year twothirds of the cash returned by
US companies was in the form of
buybacks. 924 billion got returned in
buybacks about 650 billion in dividends.
This is no
longer something that's going to pass.
This is clearly a long time longterm
long-term shift in how companies return
cash to their shareholders. So I have a
I have a basic question about I mean
let's focus on the US. Clearly this is
happening. Why do you think companies
have shifted
away from paying dividends to and every
answer you give I'm going to pass to the
test of hey can this explain what
happened before 1990 as well right
because if your reason is this is why
you see the shift I'm going to say well
if that's the case then why didn't you
see more of it before so why do you
think companies have shifted away from
dividends to
buybacks and you must have some some
hypothesis, throw it out there and we'll
kind of drag it through the process. Why
do you think companies have shifted away
from dividends to buybacks?
Yes, Kelly.
They're not committed to it. Okay. So,
why didn't this apply before 1990? Why
were we willing to commit before 1990,
but we're not willing to commit in 2021
or 2022?
I mean, it's always been true that
dividends have been sticky and buybacks
are easy. So why did people suddenly
wake up to that in 1985 when they had
that choice in 70? Nothing in the law
has changed. You've always been able to
buy back stock, but something seemed to
trigger that switch of hey, we can buy
back stock. So let's file that away. So
it's clear dividends are less require
have require commitment. Buybacks don't.
But that's always been true. So why is
that more of a factor now than it was 40
years ago? But are there let's let's
look to some of the other reasons that
get thrown out for this as well. What
what what else can explain dividends by
that? Could it be tax
court? Tax code actually pushes in the
opposite direction, right? Because I
remember I told you that until you get
to
2004, dividends were taxed at a higher
rate than capital gains. Dividends at a
disadvantage.
If taxes were your reason, you should
actually see more dividends now and less
buybacks because the tax reason for not
paying dividends has kind of gone
away. Anything else that might have
changed? There has to be something that
changed at companies, right, Kelly?
Something else that might have changed
at companies that explains this?
I was thinking like more recessions and
everything. firms don't want to be stuck
to paying dividends. Maybe they had
negative more recessions. Actually,
there have been fewer recessions in the
last 34 years than before, right?
Recessions have actually become more
infrequent rather than more
frequent. This one clue is when did it
start? 1990s. What what kinds of
companies entered the market? has to be
with like tech companies that forward to
increase like they focus more on
increase the value of the companies
rather than returning that's a very
dangerous follow-up statement everybody
wants to increase the value of the
companies right so in a sense it's not
just tech companies every but there is a
reason there there's something to do
with tech companies and how they
I guess they're all public I was going
to say but some of the smaller companies
people want to get shares but maybe
don't want to compensation. Let's make
that about share. So if you care about
share price as a manager because you're
compensated based on share price. You
have options as part of your
compensation package. Remember what
dividends do right the minute you pay a
dividend your stock price drops. You're
saying I'm going to be focused. So it's
not just value. It's per share price
that you care about because your
compensation is early on. That was the
reason given for this surge was in the
1990s you have a lot of tech companies
paying people with options. They care
about the price. So given a choice
between paying our dividends and buying
back
stock, they're going to buy back
stock. But here's the problem with that
reason today. First, today if you look
at how companies pay their employees,
they pay them with restricted stock
where you get dividends on those stuff.
Now 90% of stockbased compensation now
is restricted stock. only 10% is option
based. Second, when you look at who buys
back stock, it's across the board.
Every, it's not just tech companies.
It's every company in every sector,
small companies, large
companies. So, it might have been
started by the share price fixation at
companies and management compensation,
but that reason seems to have
dissipated.
It's not taxes. But I think Kelly is two
of the parts of what go into the right
answer. First is you know she said the
dividends require commitment buybacks
are more flexible and the second part
she talked about not just recessions but
economic
uncertainty. In my piece on
globalization I talked about the good
side of globalization right we all have
more choices. Companies can expand
anywhere they want. But there is a flip
side of glo globalization which is it's
made uncertainty about your business
greater across the board. Why? Because
you no longer have nice local markets
you dominate and not have to worry about
competition because before you know it a
Chinese company can make things at half
the price you made and there goes your
nice predictable market.
I'll wager that 40 years ago if you're
listing our 200 companies with nice
predictable earnings, you'd have had no
trouble coming up with that
list in the US or even in much of the
world because you had n companies that
essentially dominated domestic markets
had predictability and especially in the
US which had the most predictable
mean-reverting economy. You felt pretty
comfortable about your future not just
about earnings today but about your
predictable earnings. you were willing
to make that commitment to pay dividends
because you felt that your long-term
earnings was secure and pretty
predictable. You'd have trouble finding
I was going to say 10 companies, but one
company today that feels that the future
is predictable enough that you're
willing to commit to making a payment
that you have to make every year. The
world has become a more uncertain place.
And as it becomes more uncertain, it
becomes more and more difficult to go
out and say, "I'm willing to pay $5 in
dividends this year and every year
forever." I'll give you the analogy, and
it might be a little off-putting, but
hang in there with me anyway, of why I
think dividends have been displaced by
buybacks and why this isn't going to
change.
My daughter turned 30 over the weekend.
She's also pregnant, so a lot of big
things coming at her. She's due in four
weeks. But I remember when she was 7
years
old, age ago, and I had to drive her to
a birthday
party, get in the car. She was tiny. She
was like 55 pounds even at 7 years old.
So she still had to be in a car seat.
She's strapped in and she demands that I
change the radio station. I listen to
jazz and she thought it was whiny. So
she said, "I want to listen to the
Z100." So I turn on to Z100 and I think
they play the same song over and over
again all day long like different
versions of song and between every third
or fourth song, the DJ comes on for the
PA where they talk to each other. They
talk about hooking
up. How disconnected you get after 30
years of marriage. I had no idea what
they were talking about.
And my seven-year-old from the back
seat starts to explain to me what
hooking up
is. Part of me is in
shock and the other part of me, the way
she was explaining it was very
disjointed, but I kind of got right. But
the other part of me says, "This is a
great way to explain why companies have
moved from
dividends to buybacks."
How many of you are married? Hey,
remember the marriage
vows in good times and in bad through
you know through bad. I've forgotten.
I'm terrible. I actually cannot remember
any lines. No, but but the marriage
you're for the rest of your life,
right? Hooking up is nice today. I
wouldn't see you tomorrow. I don't even
remember your
name.
Companies don't want to get married
anymore. Investors don't want to get
married. Dividends are like getting
married. Buybacks are like hooking up.
Companies are hooking up. That's
basically what they're doing. Nice three
billion. Good year. Don't expect this
next year. I won't even remember who you
are. But that's okay. The world is
shifting and it's you're seeing this in
both you know in on both sides it's not
just companies investors don't have any
loyalty to companies it's not I mean my
parents have comp shares in their
portfolio and I asked them when how did
you get this I don't remember happened
in the 1960s it's still
there I don't touch things there it just
stays there that's no longer the case
investors move in and out of stocks
companies essenti
No, and I don't think this is going to
shift. It reflects a very changed
universe of the relationship between
companies and
investors. And I think, you know,
legislators are a little concerned about
buybacks. We'll talk about good and bad
reasons to be concerned. So last year,
what did uh the latest budget
reconciliation bring in especially for
buybacks?
is something that was added to the tax
code last year, specifically directed
buybacks. You
remember you're a company that buys back
stock now, you have to pay a 1%
tax just on the buyback amount. It's not
stop companies. They're still paying it
out. But that 1% can become 5 10 15 20
50. It's essentially no. And in fact,
this might be a good point to stop and
ask why are
legislators worried about
buybacks, but they don't seem to be
concerned about they both return take
cash out of the company, right? So, what
is it about buybacks? Give me the bad
side. The the side that says, "Look, but
there's actually a group of people who
think buybacks should be bad, that
they're bad for companies, bad for the
economy." So can somebody play the role
of you know why buybacks should be
banned know what's what is it about
buybacks that troubles people and leads
legislators to put a tax on buybacks
slows investment right basically money
that's bought back is not invested back
in the company and that's bad right is
it do we want GM to be investing
more money back into its
business.
Why you think it's good for the economy?
Is it again good for the economy? There
are all these assumptions we make,
right? Companies investing more is
better than companies investing
less. We know that's not true already
because in this class we talked about
when investments add value and when they
destroy value. And if you take
investments that earn well below your
cost of capital, you're destroying
value. Why would I want those companies
investing back? You see, it grows the
economy. There in lies the second worry
about buybacks. That somehow this money
is sucked into a giant vacuum and it
kind of disappears. Where did the $924
billion that was used to buy back stock
last year
go into somebody's pockets, right? What
did they do? Stupid things like pay
bills. But but that was only a small
portion. Most of it went back
where? Into the market into other
companies. The money that is used for
buybacks doesn't disappear from the
investment pool. It gets reinvested by
somebody else. So instead of GM
investing your money, Nvidia invests
your
money. That's basically what So the
question here is not does do buybacks
reduce investment. It's who makes the
investments. By banning buybacks, you're
going to get companies essentially
investing money across the board. But
many of these companies be investing in
businesses that are businesses that
really have no escape hatch, no future.
I think in fact buybacks are healthy
because they move money out of companies
that don't have a use for the money, at
least a good use, into companies that
don't.
Now you take apart take away the last
month the last few month if you look at
the last 20 years of what's happened in
equity markets around the world I mean
clearly equity markets like China and
India risk Europe and Japan in terms of
market cap have become a smaller slice
of equity
markets but there's one market that's
actually started as a big market has
become even bigger and it's a US it
started at about a third of all US
equities 20 years ago
It's now
50% of global equities. And it's not
because old US companies have held the
fort, right? They've shrunk, but what
you have are companies like Facebook, 13
years old, is a is a very young company,
but it's worth more than a trillion and
a half. And one of the reasons I think
the US has been able to kind of fight
off that aging effect is because
buybacks have shifted cash within the US
from older companies that have no use
and allowed the funding of younger
companies that have essentially taken up
the slack. Europe has had much tighter
restrictions and buybacks. They have a
whole host of other
issues. They're much tougher
restrictions and buybacks. And you look
at the European equity markets, take a
look at the 100 largest European stocks
in in terms of market gap. Tell me how
many young companies you find on that
list. Hardly
any. So when we talk through this
legislation on buybacks, we can talk
about when companies shouldn't be buying
back stock. I do think Boeing bought
back too much stock especially in those
years leading into this crisis because
they could have very well used that ca
that cash now to kind of recreate or re
you know come back with credibility
create a new aircraft so do companies
sometimes buy back stock when they
shouldn't be absolutely but you could
say that about almost every corporate
action would have a blanket limit on
buybacks I think it's dangerous because
it leaves cash in the hands of
businesses that really don't need that
cash, don't have a good use for the
cash, and now you're going to make them
invest that cash. So, if anybody says
it's better to invest than not invest,
not true. I don't want more Bed Bath and
Beyond around me. I don't even think I
want more Chipotles opening up. And I
definitely don't want 10 more Starbucks
in the six block neighborhood I'm in.
Right. We don't want some companies to
invest more. We want other companies to
invest more and the only way to get
capital across quickly is to take is to
have the companies that have too much
cash return the cash and then that cash
gets reinvested. So as you watch the
debate about buybacks kind of play out.
Watch for all these false premises on
which these debates are you know based
that buybacks essentially take cash out
of the market. No they don't. They just
move cash around that they cause a drop
in investment. No they don't. to cause a
different kind of investment. And if you
don't like it, have a policy statement
about why you think tech company
investing is worse than retail company
investing, opening stores, and let's
hear it out. Let's play that debate out
because that's really the debate we
should be
having. As I said, in the the 80s,
buybacks were rare in the US. They've
taken off and for a long time, the US
was unique. Most of the markets stayed
with no
buybacks but it's clearly a phenomenon
that is going global. So this is in
2024 I've listed out by by sub region.
So small Asia is Asia without India,
China and Japan, Latin America and the
Caribbean. So if you feel that I've
somehow insulted your country by putting
it in the wrong region, I am truly sorry
I had to put it somewhere.
So for instance I've Australia, New
Zealand, Canada, China. So essentially
I've tried to break it out by market
size. There are the number of firms
within each market. The percentage of
companies within each region that pay
dividends. See Chinese companies 77% of
Chinese companies are dividend payers.
The total dollar dividends paid and the
dividend yield. We're going to come back
and talk more about dividend yield.
What's the definition of a dividend
yield? What do I divide dividends by to
get dividend
yield? The pay that's payout ratio. Net
income would be payout ratio. Market cap
would be the dividend yield. So it's a
so it's a portion of your returns that
come from dividends. So it varies widely
across the world. The US is one of the
lowest dividend yields in the world. But
it's giving you only a piece of the
puzzle,
right? But I've also looked at the
percent of the companies that buy back
stock. The US is the highest at 46% of
companies. So this is no longer just
tech companies. It's half the market,
the companies in the market. In fact, a
much higher percentage of US companies
pay dividends than pay pay buyback stock
than pay dividends now
45.6%. There's the amount
returned more than a trillion
dollars in cash in 2024 and the
percentage of cash returned. But the key
is if you look across the rest of the
world that number is not zero anymore.
20 years ago it would have been the US
net 35% then and the rest of the world
was 0%. You can look at the UK. You can
look at Japan. Now Japan is actually my
what's my biggest surprise here? Because
the Japanese companies have
traditionally been driven by inertia.
They're reluctant to change. But even
Japanese companies have joined in this
process of buying back stock. the parts
of the world where it's least
seen, Eastern Europe and Russia, no
buybacks. You're saying, "Let's put
pressure on Russian companies to buy
back stock. Good luck with that." Right?
So, this is tied to the corporate
governance component, which corporate
governance is weak. You're not going to
see it. But India, for instance, less
than 10% of cash returned is in the form
of
buybacks. It's still rare in India. Part
of it might still be laws on the books
that make it more difficult to buy back
stock than dividends, but I'll wager 10
years from now when you look at these
statistics that more cash across the
world is going to be returned in
buybacks and dividends. And I think it's
a good thing for me. Dividends are the
problem, not the buybacks, cuz they
don't fit my version of residual cash
flows.
So this might be a good time to ask why
did companies start on this fixed
dividend
policy? What now? How do you get
started? It's insane, right? To pay a
fixed
dividend to investors who get a residual
cash flow. What do you think created
this process where companies started
paying fixed dividends? Must have
started somewhere. Somebody must have
said this is a good
idea. Which market came first? The bond
market or the stock market?
In terms of history, which markets
were the bond market predated the stock
market? There were bond markets before
stock markets exist. People bought bonds
with the coupons and the cash flows. I
mean, companies like the East India
Company issued bonds before they would
borrow money from the public with bonds.
So much of the market, you know,
investors were used to the bond market.
What do you get in the bond market? You
bought a bond, you got a fixed coupon.
So let's say you're the the guy IPOing
the entire equity asset class. What do
you have to do? You have to get
investors who are used to bonds to try
to buy stocks, right? You can already
see how this is going to play out. How
do you make stocks look like bonds? You
tell investors they'll pay a dividend.
And by the way, we can't contractually
guarantee the dividend, but we're going
to try to pay at least this amount every
year.
You can see the start of a rigid
dividend policy. People were investing
in stocks, collecting dividends like
they were coupons. And what did they
expected to do? Continue to pay not just
the last dividend, but perhaps a little
higher, 2% more every year because you
were getting a coupon with an inflation
component built in the
1800s. And then it got built into how
companies paid dividends. And you look
at dividends today, they still reflect
that
history. The problem is a 100 years ago,
the kinds of companies that were raising
money in capital markets tend to be
established companies, railroads,
utilities. It was okay paying dividends.
And you look at the kinds of companies
going public today. A palunteer in what
universe can a palunteer promise a fixed
dividend be able to
deliver? Or a Door Dash?
The world has become more uncertain and
it's dividends that really have to
change. You don't like buybacks, do
special dividends where essentially
dividends are going to reflect what you
can afford to pay. Tie them to how
you're doing it because just like you
match debt up to the assets, you want to
match what you pay out to your
shareholders to what you can afford to
pay
out. So buybacks are not going away.
They're just going to get bigger.
They're going to go global. You're going
to see this phenomenon kind of spread
across companies because no company in
its right mind should be going out and
saying we'll pay $2 in dividends this
year and increase that by 3% every year
for the next 50 years because you can't
have the earnings to back it
up. So as the last part of today, let's
look at your company. So when you get a
chance, I'd like you to take a look at
the dividends your company. Let's focus
on dividends first, then talk about the
buybacks. Where would you find the data
on dividends for your company? What what
financial
statement? Go to the statement of cash
flows. Under that section on financing
cash flows, if there are dividends,
there should be dividends paid. In fact,
it's the same section. You also see the
buybacks, right? Is it possible that
your company doesn't pay
dividends? In fact, you're the rule, not
the exception.
Most of the companies in this
class you won't see any dividends. How
do I know that? Because most US
companies don't pay
dividends. But some of your companies
will pay dividends. Some will pay big
dividends. So the question I ask is is
my company an outlier? How you know
given how much it pays in dividends?
Dollar dividends can't be compared
across companies for obvious reasons.
The per share number who knows what that
per share number looks like. So we need
to scale dividends to something. One is
the dividend yield and I talked about
scaling dividends to your market cap.
It's actually a kind of intuitive
measure of hey this is how much of my
return I will get from dividends. If you
remember when we used the capital asset
pricing model expected return plus beta
times equity risk feels like a throwback
in time. We got a number for Disney. It
was like 9.02%. You say what does that
mean? Well that's my total expected
return. Some of it is going to come from
dividends and some of it is going to
come from price appreciation. The
dividend yield is the portion that comes
from dividends. Dividends divided by the
market
price. But I could also divide dividends
by net income. Why? Because at least in
theory earnings are what you have to pay
out. I know it's not a cash flow.
Dividends divided by net income is
called the payout
ratio. So would you like a high payout
ratio or low payout ratio? It's not a
question of like. question of if I have
a high payout ratio, I'm paying most of
my earnings out as dividends. That's
good in terms of cash for me as an
investor, but it's bad because a lesser
percentage is being reinvested. So, I
have to accept the fact that companies
that have high payout ratios are
probably going to have low
growth. Dividend payout ratios measure
dividends relative to net income.
Dividend yields measure dividends
relative to market cap.
start of every year I actually update
these numbers for the market because I
want to get a sense of what does the
world look like in terms of yields and
payout ratios. The first one is dividend
yields in January 2025. There's the
global distribution of dividend
yields of dividend paying companies. So
let me be clear about why I'm drawing
the distinction. Many companies don't
pay dividends. If I bring them to the
graph in this graph, you know what's
going to happen? There's going to be a
huge
spike on zero dividend yields. I don't
want them in my it makes my picture look
you might not even see some of the
columns if I bring that in. So among
dividend paying companies this is what
the distribution looks
like. So there are US companies the in
the dark red and global companies in the
bright red. You already saw the dividend
yield for a US company at least across
the market is 1 to 2%. So if your
company has a dividend yield of 1 to 2%.
It's pretty much in the norm. If your
div company has a dividend yield of 3,
three and a half, 4%, it's an unusual
company. And especially as you get to 4
12% it becomes a company. Look, I said
this is amazing. I'm going to buy this
company. What's the why the four and a
half%? What's why did I use that as a
trigger? Because that's your T-bond
rate, right? You're saying, "Look, I can
invest in a T-bond, get four and a
half%." Or I can buy the stock and get a
4 and a half. Seems like a no-brainer,
right? Just buy the stock because now
you get the same return you'd have got
in a T-bond plus you get price
appreciation. This is Ben Graham value
investing because that's effectively
that entire book of security analysis
you can boil down to. I want to buy a
stock where I can collect enough cash
flow each year that covers what I could
have made by buying a bond plus I get
the price
appreciation. In fact, there's a
there there are entire investment
strategies built around buying high
dividend stocks five six 5% 6% 7%. So
you can see there are companies out
there with dividend yields that exceed
8%. And you're saying are these
companies I mean this looks like a no
you know so if I load it up on those
companies with more than 8% dividend
yields should have a great portfolio
right what can go
wrong you pay when you see a dividend
deal of 8%.
Might not be doing that. In fact it's
not even might not. These are companies
where there's a disaster. They're like
companies driving 80 m an hour with a
driver blindfolded. This is not going to
end well, right? Because when the market
price is that low, the investor is
saying this company is a basket case and
continue to return
cash. 8% dividend yields are not
sustainable. Something is going to break
here. And that's the difference. The
debond rate, the four and a half% is
guaranteed. I think it's a US Treasury.
Who knows what that might
do? But the 8% dividend deal is the
dividend deal from last year. You buy
these stocks, next thing you know, the
companies are cutting dividends or going
bankrupt on
you. But across all companies, you can
see the dividend yield varies. There are
companies that look like they're
deceptively cheap. Deceptively cheap
because the price is low, the dividends
are high. But I've never been a fan of
strategies built around buying high
dividend yields unless you've taken a
really close look at the companies. And
most of those companies when you look at
the companies and we'll talk about the
metrics you can look at those dividends
are
unsustainable. But the median dividend
year for all
companies is 0%. Why? Because there are
more companies that don't pay dividends
than don't. These are just the dividend
paying companies. Let's look at the
payout ratio here. Again, remember I'm
dividing the dividends by the earnings.
The ratio is going to be 0% if you pay
no dividends. It's going to be 100% if
you pay all your earnings out as
dividends. But there's this extra column
of companies that pay out more than
100%. It's not small. About 15, 16, 17%
of companies have payout ratios that
exceed
100%. Now, these companies might be
crazy. So let that decide. But there are
rational explanations and good reasons
why a company might choose to pay out
more than 100% of its earnings as
dividends. Way do you have any?
Yeah. Banks and REITs. Okay. Banks and
REITs. So let's take the REITs first.
What is it that that as a REIT that'll
lead you to pay more than 100%. Uh
qualified REITs uh have to distribute. I
believe it's like greater than 95% of
the earnings. But why would they stop at
100%. So what is it about real estate
that allows you to pay out more than
100% of earnings?
Uh they can pay out debt.
That's a dangerous reason, right? You
borrow money to pay dividends. You're
taking all it have a trick where they
can apply depreciation. Exactly. They
can pay. It's depre. So they're allowed
to add that depreciation component which
means you can get above your earnings.
But it does mean that for REITs to grow
now you have to issue fresh equity right
it's it comes with that catch right so
REITs why banks banks even in down years
a lot of them but let's focus on in down
years you pay out more than 100% hoping
what happens they have upear so in up
years you should be paying well below so
you're paying based on normalized income
so any company with a lot of cyclicality
in earnings during bad years you might
pay out more than 100% of earnings, not
because that's what you plan to do
forever, but because you think the
earnings are going to bounce back and
that you use the good years to buffer
the bad years. So it could be so not
just banks, but so REITs, it could be
cyclical companies, any other ideas and
companies that should be paying out more
than 100%. It's actually rational.
You remember the corporate life cycle
that I introduced at the start of the
class that companies grow then they
mature and then they enter into a phase
where what should they do
logically they should shrink right how
does a company
shrink you devest assets you take the
cash flows and you return them right you
can do them as buybacks but you could
also pay dividends if you have a company
whose business has turned bad it's not
going to grow it's a tobacco company
Right? What exactly you reinvesting in?
Fewer people are smoking, the business
gets smaller. You might be liquidating
yourself partially every year because
that's what paying out more than 100% of
your earnings does is it shrinks your
equity, shrinks your
company. So there are crazy reasons for
paying out more than 100% of earnings.
You do it because everybody does it. You
do it because you hope to borrow money
and it's a no, but you don't do it
consistently for those reasons. If you
want to do it consistently either
because you're in a bad business, you're
shrinking, you're a volatile business,
you expect earnings to come back. The
danger though is if earnings don't come
back, then you eventually have to return
to those dividends. Say, I can't pay
this anymore. Or it could be because
there's a quirk in the tax law, which is
what the REITs do, which allows you to
pay out more than 100% of earnings as
dividends.
And REITs have
another advantage which is in addition
to this depreciation effect they don't
pay taxes on their earnings right so
it's pre-tax income it's essentially
gets returned and the IRS is hoping to
tax you on your dividends so the IRS is
happy when more than 100% of earnings is
returned as dividends right unless they
get returned as dividends to taxexempt
institutions because then it kind of
flows into the space where it doesn't
get taxed at any level at not the
corporate level, not at the investor
level. So what I would suggest you look
at is look at your dividend yield and
payout ratio for your companies very
quickly. You know, you can do it in two
minutes. See what your company pays out
in dividends. So next session, we're
going to talk about the tradeoff that
drives dividends, but it'll be after the
quiz. So I'll talk to you on Wednesday.
There will I will have office hours this
Sunday. So I'll send you again those two
hours. So if you have
questions,
Congratulations on the soon to be
um
with that being said, rumor has it that
you won't be here next year. I don't
know if that's a rumor.
Yeah, it makes sense.
Anymore or next year? I'll be back. But
you're gonna stay on next year, right?
No, no, no.
I'll be back.
Back with a vengeance.
Back with a vengeance. Back with a
vengeance.
Oh, I just wanted to double check on
that. Uh, thank you.